[Music]
yes so I wrote this book to give a lens
to people to view the world differently
it's something that we take for granted
every day the kind of rules that we
follow they're omnipresent but they're
invisible so from the moment we wake up
until the moment you go to sleep
we're following rules you know most of
us put clothes on before we go out in
the street
most of us ride on the right side or the
left side depending on where we live we
say hello and goodbye on the phone we
follow these rules all the time but some
groups have very strong rules they're
what I call tight cultures where there's
strong rules and little tolerance for
deviants and other groups what I call
loose groups are much more permissive
and they have a wide range of behavior
that scene is appropriate and this lens
is really very powerful it helps us to
understand things from politics to
parenting from Nations to neurons a
general principle about tight and loose
is that groups that have more power
living looser worlds they have more
latitude and groups that have less power
women minorities other identities that
are stigmatized they live in tighter
worlds they're subject to stronger
punishments for the same exact behavior
and I've shown this actually with some
research we published in Psych science a
journal in my field some years ago but
you can see other evidence of it all the
time you saw it in the US Open this past
weekend with Serena Williams who argued
that these reps would never call the
same kinds of punishments and penalties
on them on a white male tennis player
cultural intelligence it's more than
just knowledge about other cultures
that's certainly part of it there's one
dimension that's clearly just about
knowledge of the culture but it's also
about your motivation to interact with
people in different cultures that's
actually one of the most important parts
of cultural intelligence is having that
kind of openness to see diversity as an
opportunity versus a threat that
predicts people doing much better when
they're crossing cultures and there's
also a sense of metacognition which is a
fancy way of saying thinking about what
you know about culture questioning what
you know about it so there's multiple
dimensions of cultural intelligence and
we can assess it we can measure it and
we can use it to predict how well people
will do on international assignments in
negotiations that are cross-cultural
so it's really an incredibly important
construct and again in this globalized
era we really need to move beyond IQ and
EQ you can have great intelligence but
have no cultural intelligence you can
have emotional intelligence but you can
also fail on CQ so it's really an
incredibly important attribute to
cultivate and the kids have been
noticing this as females they say you
know mom we're living in a tighter world
than our male counterparts and when they
play sports you hear the referee's
whistle going off way more and so I
think it's also important that to train
them to think about the world they're
living in to think about how they
themselves are you know going out in the
world are going to be subject to the
strength of norms and to try to think
about how to negotiate that
you